one of the main things professional
prototype errs and UX engineers do is
build out prototypes in code often we
use things like framer j/s sublime text
Android studio or Xcode with these tools
we can make prototypes of arbitrary
fidelity this is really useful when you
have a particular feature that needs to
be seen to be understood often users
will have trouble understanding such a
feature from a low or medium fidelity
prototype since it doesn't always come
through in those mediums by building out
a Minimum Viable version of that feature
we can test whether it makes sense to
build a production quality version later
on another use case that makes code
prototypes vital is dealing
realistically with user input we use
this when making prototypes for Google
Maps we want to understand how the
changes impact a user's ability to find
the information they're looking for
building a prototype that leverages real
data and user input can provide valuable
insight into how a user approaches the
app remember that Jeremy wanted to type
his information when presented with our
envision prototype